entire novels and even a version of the  book of genesis have been written  without using the letter e even once  it's called constrained writing and i  find this stuff really impressive i love  it but today i wanted to show off my  favorite michael keith's not awake this  uses every letter in the modern english  alphabet so what's its constraint well  let's start reading  now i fall a tired suburban in liquid  under the trees drifting alongside  forests simmering red in the twilight  over europe  how many letters are in each of those  words  3 1 4 1 5 9 2 6  eight nine seven nine three two three  eight four six  pi  it is a ten thousand word book of poetry  plays and puzzles in which the number of  letters in each next word exactly  follows the decimal value of pi